operativa y técnicamente que haría falta
para que esta propuesta se concrete pues
tiene que haber un aumento del esfuerzo
de momento bilateral de manera bilateral
o conteniendo un país miembro la unión
europea como ya se está haciendo
alemania por ejemplo que invita a
oficiales o soldados ucranianos de
entrenarse pero donde también tengo
entendido participan miembros de otros
países de la unión europea que lo son
también de la organización del tratado
del atlántico norte otan para entrenar
en armamento pues moderno europeo de
estándar de la otan a los ucranianos y
los británicos ya lo están haciendo
claro el reino unido ya no es de la
unión europea eres miembro de la otan es
un socio de la unión europea y también
me imagino sería útil no sé igual no se
está discutiendo que cualquier proceso
de colaboración a nivel de la unión
europea para coordinar esfuerzos o
acelerar el entrenamiento de las tropas
ucranianas en equipo moderno y el
suministro de armamento adicional para
los ucranianos que además de aumentar la
producción de esos arsenales ya agotados
en los países que han estado dando
armamento cráneo pues que incluya
también al reino unido como socio al
menos europeo y de vigo europeo no de la
unión europea pero del continente y de
la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte ante un objetivo común
que es reforzar la defensa de ucrania
ante la agresión rusa y prepararse ante
la posible guerra con rusia por el apoyo
que europa le da a ucrania le pregunto
qué alcance tendría esta misión de
entrenamiento porque sabemos que han
sido muy claros son decir que no van a
luchar en terreno
sí bueno se puede decir que ucrania está
combatiendo para la otan o sea que la
otan está peleando a través de ucrania
obviamente no es el propósito de esta
guerra no es algo maquiavélico que fue
su la otan está usando ucrania para
atacar o agredir a rusia bla bla bla
como diría la propaganda moscovita pero
es una necesidad que como la otan de los
países europeos los miembros de la unión
europea más vamos a añadir el reino
unido y no quieren pues entrar en una
guerra abierta con rusia pero tampoco
quieren que ucrania sucumba porque ya
saben motivos geopolíticos si rusia es
la intención de putin aparentemente ha
sido quedarse con toda ucrania eso le
hubiera dado frontera común con polonia
con eslovaquia con hungría con rumanía
entonces claro no hay que permitir que
eso ocurra
y que se fortalezca a rusia con los
recursos humanos industriales y
económicos que tiene ucrania si se
llegara a tragar así que la otan lo que
está haciendo y hay que añadir eeuu y
canadá en norteamérica están apoyando a
ucrania para impedir que rusia se
reconstituya como un imperio continental
de mayor envergadura como lo fue en
tiempo soviético de los zares que sería
para prácticamente la gran rusia lo que
putin persigue empezando en este caso
por ucrania así que en la envergadura
bueno lo malo es que la guerra es a
largo plazo en qué sentido como europa
no quiere que se pierde ucrania no
quiere que rusia se fortalezca ni
siquiera quedándose aunque sea con la
mitad de ucrania porque hay una cosa si
rusia se contentará como algunos dicen
bueno que ucrania debe de ceder
territorio ya que aceptarían una parte
para después volver a atacar así que yo
diría que esto da para largo porque por
un lado no pueden darse el lujo de dejar
de entrenar a los ucranianos para
resistir a los rusos hay un problema no
le están dando quizá la cantidad de
armamento que ucrania querría para
rápidamente recuperar su territorio
entonces es como a cuentagotas
tiempo los europeos tienen que recuperar
sus arsenales que están agotados porque
no olvidemos décadas en que se cree que
como ya no hay unión soviética no hay
conflicto con rusia entonces como
alemania en tiempos de angela merkel en
particular se fueron desarmando
exportando sus tanques y tienes el
problema en la economía mundial la
subida de todo de la inflación de los
precios y ahí habrá un paréntesis
pequeño y termino no es sólo un problema
ya económico de la unión europea de la
energía de la inflación la subida del
dólar hace bajar el valor de la libra y
de las monedas europeas o sea que algo
que realmente no tendría vinculación con
la guerra de ucrania y que es la
política económica la reserva federal
americana también estaría afectando la
capacidad de los europeos de financiar
la guerra y buscar alternativas
energéticas más económicas